[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den sport
ein schüler von mir und das sind unsere
themen heute wieder regen im westen neue
unwetter erschweren die dringend
notwendige hilfe in den
hochwassergebieten prozesse dagegen
macros corona politik in frankreich
demonstrieren zehntausende gegen den
neuen gesundheits und durchwachsener
deutscher start bei olympia die
beachvolleyballerinnen verlieren knapp
henning röhl leitner schwimmt dagegen
souverän ins finale über 400 meter
freistil
wir beginnen in den flutgebieten eines
können die menschen dort gerade
überhaupt nicht gebrauchen neuen regen
und neue unwetter entsprechend bank geht
der blick im moment in den himmel und
auf die wetterkarten jetzt gerade ziehen
neue gewitter vor allem über den süden
und westen von deutschland starkregen
und sturmböen können dabei sein
die betroffenen vor ort müssen sich auf
neue probleme einstellen und vorbereiten
zehn tage nach der tödlichen flut thomas
garcia berichtet ein kurzer regenguss
bin schuld wieder kommt wasser dort wo
die flut kam bisher nicht viel nicht
anhaltend nicht unheil bringen
dennoch die anwohner beunruhigt problem
neues regenwasser kann kaum ablaufen
helfer versuchen die gullys und kanäle
frei zu bekommen
auch in bächen und flüssen zu viel
treibgut es könnte mitgerissen werden
oder zu neuen überschwemmungen führen
landkreis und bundeswehr warnen
[Musik]
auch hier ist vorsicht lebenswichtig
erftstadt blessem nordrhein westfalen
dort hinten 80 meter hinter der sperre
riss ein erdrutsch häuser fort neuer
regen vielleicht neue abgänge so die
befürchtung
yamaguchi jede jede minute auf die
wetter app und so weiter auch wieder
losgehen könnte häufig entwickeln sich
gewitter so schnell dass wir erst eine
halbe stunde vorher sagen können wo sie
denn sich bildet und manchmal haben so
gewitterzellen auch die angewohnheit
einfach anders zu ziehen als es
ursprünglich aussah und schlagen so ein
haken das macht die gewitter prognose
wirklich sehr sehr kompliziert und
schwierig ein problem wäre zu viel neues
wasser ein problem sind zu viele private
helfer hunderte reisen spontan am
wochenende an im landkreis ahrweiler
spricht der katastrophenschutz vom
verkehrsinfarkt und chaos vor ort das
führt zu massiven störungen bei den
kräften die von unserer seite eingesetzt
deswegen möchten wir gerade jetzt auch
bedingt durch die witterung alle spontan
höhere auffordern heute im laufe des
nachmittags das gebiet zunächst zu
verlassen
die polizei kontrolliert nun dass nicht
alle auf einmal kommen alle loben die
hilfsbereitschaft sagen aber auch die
wird in ein paar wochen immer noch
gebraucht
susanne gelhard ist für uns vor ort in
bad neuenahr-ahrweiler
wie ist die wettersituation hier hat es
heute stundenweise geregnet dann wieder
die sonne scheint und trotzdem die
menschen sind besorgt denn auch hier ist
die kanalisation komplett verstopft
durch den schlamm und die iaa ist noch
lange nicht freigeräumt von müll
die menschen hier sind deswegen sehr
besorgt der katastrophenstab rheinland
pfalz hat ihnen evakuierung und
unterbringung in notunterkünften
angeboten
aber die meisten bleiben eben doch
lieber zu hause sie sind alarmiert aber
viele sind eben nicht panisch sie sind
alarmiert und sie sind weiter sehr
verzweifelt und hat eine ärztin heute
gesagt es ist der pure alptraum und dann
kommt man nach hause und denke das ist
alles vorbei und ihr albtraum möchte
einfach nicht aufhören
wir hoffen das beste dankeschön susanne
gelhard
noch ist das komplette ausmaß der
schäden nicht zu beziffern aber die
betroffenen können schon finanzielle
unterstützung beantragen
rheinland-pfalz und nordrhein-westfalen
haben soforthilfe zugesagt bis zu 3500
euro pro haushalt und bis zu 5000 euro
für gewerbetreibende
damit es schnell geht soll auf prüfungen
von bedürftigkeit oder vermögen
verzichtet werden
wie das klappt zeigen angeliefert und
heike kruse generatoren und pumpen
drohen hier an der ahr den ganzen tag
die menschen wollen einfach irgendwie
ihr lebensumfeld vom schlamm befreien
in der wohnung von fabian knieps und
seiner freundin stand das wasser bis zum
ersten stock das mobiliar unbrauchbar
entsorgt die staatliche soforthilfe hat
er bereits beantragt
schnell unbürokratisch und großzügig
bund und länder wollen die vom
hochwasser betroffenen menschen mit
einer soforthilfe von insgesamt 400
millionen euro unterstützen
der antrag auf diese hilfe umfasst nur
die nötigsten angaben die höhe der summe
richtet sich nach der anzahl der
personen im haushalt die zuwendung
beträgt maximal 3500 euro je haushalt
1500 euro haushaltsvorstand und 500 euro
je weitere personen fabian knieps und
seine freundin bekommen also wenn alles
gutgeht 2000 euro soforthilfe soll ja
erst mal dazu dienen dass man am anfang
auch liquiditätsengpässe überbrücken
kann und natürlich reizt das nicht aus
um aufzubauen
auch werner bach kämpft im garten seines
hauses mit den schlammmassen seine frau
hat die soforthilfe direkt auf dem handy
beantragt eine eingangsbestätigung haben
sie auch schon garten und haus zerstört
die finanzielle unterstützung willkommen
mal
nicht nur privatpersonen auch
unternehmen können sofort hilfe
beantragen für betroffene betriebe
stehen 5000 euro zur verfügung
viele menschen in brandenburg wissen was
es bedeutet wenn so viel zerstört ist
1997 haben sie ähnliches erlebt bei der
oderflut auch damals kam hilfe aus ganz
deutschland auch damals hatte man sich
fest vorgenommen aus der katastrophe zu
lernen und sich künftig besser zu
wappnen was daraus geworden ist zeigt
jan meyer vor genau 24 jahren versank
die ziltendorfer niederung in den oder
fluten seitdem gibt es immer ende juli
eine gedenkveranstaltung dieses mal wird
die erinnerung besonders lebendig durch
die hochwasserkatastrophe am rhein
wenn man das alles sieht also uns
standen die tränenden augen es war
wieder alles so hautnah die ganzen
müllberge rechts und links der straße
des hamburger erlebten ich und aber man
muss die hoffnung geben weitergeben und
auch die hoffnung haben damals hatten
wir die hilfe von ganz deutschland und
haben wieder aufbauen können
nach dem oder hochwasser wurde der 185
kilometer langer deich entlang des
grenzflusses von grund auf saniert
seitdem gab es hier keine
überschwemmungen mehr
doch die arbeiten an den
hochwasserschutzanlagen gehen weiter es
ist leider so im zuge des klimawandels
dass wir auch mit zunehmend höheren und
länger andauernden hochwasserereignissen
rechnen müssen dass die anlagen werden
größer höher zum teil auch breiter damit
sie einfach längere stabilität haben mit
landeshilfe bauen städte ihre
kanalisation aus damit im notfall
überschüssiges wasser schnell ablaufen
kann
doch besonders gefährdete gebiete werden
wohl auch künftig nicht geschützt werden
können
ich glaube dass wir bei der
bauleitplanung in den städten in der tat
ein umdenken brauchen wir müssen viel
stärker vom wasser her denken innovative
maßnahmen von grünen dächern über grün
fassaden bis hin zu mulden und baum
rigolen ganz viel mit denken und das
bedeutet eben auch dass wir an der einen
stelle sagen werden müssen da können wir
nicht mehr wahr
die oder blieb in diesem jahr in ihrem
flussbett doch irgendwann das wissen
auch die menschen hier wird es wieder
hochwasser geben
schauen wir auf die korona lage in
deutschland
die sieben tage incident steigt weiter
auf jetzt 13,6 vor einer woche lag sie
noch unter 10
das robert koch institut meldete 1919
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden 311
mehr als vor einer woche
28 neue todesfälle wurden innerhalb
eines tages registriert frankreich geht
im kampf gegen korona weiter als
deutschland
dort soll es eine impfpflicht geben für
alle die im gesundheitswesen oder im
rettungsdienst arbeiten und einen
gesundheitspass als nachweis für
impfungen oder negativer tests
die mehrheit der franzosen ist dafür
aber es gibt auch vehemente proteste
heute demonstrierten landesweit wieder
zehntausende aus paris thomas walther
freiheit freiheit rufen sie in marseille
bordeaux ex und auch in paris tausende
kritisieren so die antico witt maßnahmen
der regierung
man kann für gewöhnlich wählen ob man
sich impfen lässt oder nicht aber diese
freiheit gibt es nicht mehr
ich fürchte wir werden wie china ein
land der totalen kontrolle
die kritik richtet sich insbesondere
gegen den sogenannten gesundheitspass
den muss vorliegen wir ins museum möchte
ins kino oder in ein restaurant
auch an anderen öffentlichen orten
verlangt die regierung künftig von allen
über zwölf jahren den nachweis dass sie
geimpft genesen oder getestet sind
beschäftigte im gesundheitswesen müssen
sich impfen lassen die
nationalversammlung nahm das
entsprechende gesetz an der
gesundheitspass ist keine strafe die
menschen zugänge untersagt er ist das
einzige instrument mit dem wir
verhindern können alle öffentlichen orte
beim wiederaufflammen der academy
verschließen
tatsächlich steigen die zahlen vor allem
in den feriengebieten massiv an pro tag
infizieren sich mehr als 20.000 menschen
in frankreich mit dem virus der die
regierung den druck erhöht nehmen die
impfungen deutlich zu auch bei urlaubern
und angesichts der ergriffenen maßnahmen
und dem druck vor dem neuen schuljahr
haben gehen uns entschlossen uns gleich
hier impfen zu lassen
ein testzentrum am fuß des eiffelturms
solche tests sind künftig nicht mehr
kostenlos
auch das soll den impf druck erhöhen die
von der regierung beschlossenen
maßnahmen gelten übrigens auch für
touristen
der zusammenschluss der beiden größten
deutschen wohnungs konzerne ist offenbar
gescheitert die wo novia hatte die
deutsche wohnen übernehmen wollen doch
deren aktionäre stimmten bis zum
stichtag nicht mit mehrheit zu gemeinsam
hätten den beiden unternehmen mehr als
eine halbe million wohnungen gehört die
geplante fusion hatte die debatte um
mietsteigerungen und knappen wohnraum
weiter angefacht
nach einem jahr corona pause gab es
heute in berlin wieder eine große parade
zum christopher street day
trotz sicherheitsvorkehrungen und
alkoholverbot waren rund 35.000 menschen
gekommen um zu feiern
vor allem aber auch um flagge zu zeigen
für die rechte sexueller minderheiten im
focus vor allem die situation in polen
und ungarn dort in ungarn fürchten viele
dass die diskriminierung homosexueller
noch zunimmt schließlich will der rechts
konservative premier orban ein gesetz
durchsetzen
das frei zugängliche informationen über
andere als heterosexuelle lebensweisen
verbietet vom csd in budapest berichtet
wolf christian ullrich die pride
demonstration in budapest ist heute
größer als sonst was die menschen auf
die straße treibt ein neues gesetz der
orban regierung das vorsieht dass ungarn
unter 18 nichts mehr über homo und
transsexualität erfahren dürfen
sie wollen uns aus der öffentlichkeit
streichen aus den medien und aus den
schulen
was das konkret bedeutet zeigt sich an
diesem buch laden das geschäft sieht
sich dazu gezwungen solche schilder
anzubringen hier werden nicht
traditionelle inhalte verkauft gemeint
sind damit kinderbücher wie dieses in
der eine familie mit zwei papas zu sehen
ist
wir wissen nicht was andeutung von
homosexualität bedeuten soll verklagt
der buchhändler dann muss man den
schülern auf shakespeare rambo und
thomas mann verbergen
auch mitglieder des europäischen
parlaments sind nach budapest gekommen
die eu sieht die achtung der gleichheit
und menschenwürde im eu-vertrag verletzt
und hat deshalb ein
vertragsverletzungsverfahren gegen
ungarn auf den weg gebracht dies ist
inakzeptabel in europa es geht hier um
grundrechte demokratie gibt es nicht
ohne rechtsstaatlichkeit
ungarns ministerpräsident orban hat
jetzt ein referendum über das gesetz
angekündigt für ihn ist der streit
munition für den kommenden wahlkampf
über jahre hinweg hat die regierung
orban auf dem rücken von minderheiten
wahlkampf gemacht wie wut darüber ist
hier heute groß von der eu erhofft man
sich klare kante demokratie sagen sie
hier heißt auch minderheiten zu schützen
die pyramiden von gizeh oder das
dresdner elbtal gehören schon zum
weltkulturerbe heute die kommission der
unesco weitere regionen rund um den
globus in diese riege aufgenommen in
deutschland können sich die kurorte bad
ems und bad kissingen über die ehre
freuen sowie baden-baden mit dem kurhaus
und seinen vielen parkanlagen außerdem
auf der liste die mathildenhöhe in
darmstadt ein einzigartiges jugendstil
ensemble samt russischer kapelle
tja und jetzt nach tokio da gab es heute
zwar noch keine medaille für deutschland
aber erste erfolge und auch faustdicke
überraschungen
henning müller hat den deutschen olympia
schwimmern einen start nach maß beschert
der 24 jährige schwamm als
vorlaufschnellster über 400 meter
freistil ins finale
vorfreude riss sich in den glüh leitner
nach dem rennen die badekappe vom kopf
her konnte es selbst kaum glauben
der 24-jährige hatte die konkurrenz klar
hinter sich gelassen
obwohl mühe leitner im rennen über 400
meter freistil
zunächst weiter hinten lag übernahm der
deutsche schließlich sensationell
nach etwa 250 metern die führung und
ließ sich die bis zum ziel nicht mehr
nehmen
mit persönlicher bestzeit geht
mühlleithen am morgen als favorit ins
rennen und könnte das erste olympische
edelmetall für die beckenschwimmer
[Musik]
und gut liest auch für die deutschen
ruderer am ersten wettkampftag allen
voran für den achter bei erneut
drückender hitze und hohe
luftfeuchtigkeit zog das paradeboot des
deutschen ruderverbandes auf den letzten
metern des vorlaufs auf dem south course
broadway noch an den lange führenden us
dran vorbei und sicherte sich platz eins
damit ist der deutschland-achter direkt
ins finale eingezogen
dagegen olympia fehlstart für die
deutschen handballer sie unterlagen
spanien knapp mit 27 28 in einem
spannenden aber auch hitzigen
vorrundenspiel am ende war es nicht nur
spannend die emotionen kochten richtig
hoch zwei umstrittene stürmer fouls
gegen das in schwarz gekleidete deutsche
team in den schlussminuten verhinderten
ein happy end nach spannendem kampf
mannschaft ärgerlich ist das schon aber
ich denke wir hatten schon 27 zu 28
endete der olympia-auftakt der dhb
auswahl gegen europameister spanien
bester torschütze war der starke steffen
weinhold mit fünf treffern nächste
schwere gegner der deutschen handballer
sind dann argentinien und rekord
weltmeister frankreich und wir schauen
jetzt auf andere entscheidungen und vor
entscheidungen des ersten wettkampftages
und beginnen mit dem glänzenden auftritt
des deutschen teams
jessica von bredow wandell zeigte mit
ihrer stute der lehrer den besten ritt
des tages für den kombi erhielt sie 84,3
79 punkte
der kombi ist die qualifikation für den
teamwettbewerb am dienstag und das
einzel am mittwoch die sechsfache
olympiasiegerin isabell werth reitet am
morgigen sonntag
mit einem kantersieg sind die deutschen
hockey herren in ihre medaillen mission
gestartet
sie setzten sich souverän mit 7 zu 1
gegen außenseiter kanada durch
schwieriger dürfte es am montag werden
im zweiten gruppenspiel geht es gegen
den weltmeister belgien
[Musik]
die olympiasiegerin von rio laura ludwig
und ihre neue partnerin margareta kozuch
sind mit einer niederlage ins olympische
turnier gestartet die deutschen
beachvolleyballerinnen unterlagen dem
schweizer duo häberli und betschart in
eins zu zwei sätzen und alles zu den
olympischen sommerspielen finden sie
auch in der zdf- heute- app unter
sportstudio de dort gibt es zum beispiel
bis zu zehn parallele livestreams also
langweilig wird es keinem der sich für
olympia ist es sicher nicht und ich muss
noch einen fehler korrigieren ich habe
vorhin behauptet das dresdner elbtal
würde zum weltkulturerbe zählen destatis
auch aber der titel wurde 2009 aberkannt
bitte entschuldigen sie dass und jetzt
noch das wetter der deutsche
wetterdienst waren vor gewittern und
starkregen im süden von
baden-württemberg und bayern wie es
morgen und in den nächsten tagen
weitergeht dazu gleich mehr von katja
honnefer christian sievers begrüßt sie
um 23 uhr im heute-journal wir danken
für ihr interesse wünschen ihnen alles
gute und sind morgen wieder darf wenn
sie mit auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend heute kam von südwesten
kräftige schauer und gewitter heran die
breiteten sich bis nach nordrhein
westfalen aus schon heute früh ging das
los in der eifel von all dem bemerken
sie im norden und im nordosten
deutschlands gar nichts da gab es heute
badewetter bei höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 25 und 31 grad in der eifel
hatten einige schauer aber durchaus mehr
als 20 liter regen pro quadratmeter
dabei die gute nachricht ist die
gewitter die jetzt am abend noch über
die eifel ziehen die werden sich im
laufe der nacht weiter nach norden
verziehen und dann kommt erst mal nichts
mehr nach die kräftigsten unwörter
erwarten wir in dieser nacht aber aus
den alpen heraus also im südlichen
baden-württemberg und in bayern
das können gewitter seien die mit hagel
platzregen und sturmböen verbunden sind
temperaturen in der nacht sinken im
nordosten auf 19 bis 17 grad an der
mosel werden es 13 grad und morgen
liegen dann die höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 22 grad am alpenrand und 29
grad rund um berlin und auch morgen kann
es wieder eigentlich überall gewitter
geben
die kräftigsten wohl hier im süden und
auch im nordosten und gewittrig startet
dann auch die neue woche erst am
mittwoch wird es ruhiger guten abend